The Joe Rogan experience. Will, is the man behind anatomy of the fighter.
If you ever seen any of those videos,
like particularly the most famous one was when Conor McGregor threw that Dolly
at the bus with Khabib.
Norma Madoff was on it and it became a huge part of the promotion,
which I thought was weird that it was this shameful act, right.
That he did that.
I mean it really awful cut a bunch of innocent people that were on the bus,
but they use it over and over and over again. That was your foot.
A lot of people didn't even know, including me.
No one did. Um, you know, I was telling a friend of the day, what's funny,
no one has ever heard this. But when it happened, uh,
I show could beep at the back of the bus cause he was,
had a smile on his face and I showed him and everybody else on the bus that I
actually caught Connor doing it cause they didn't really know it was Connor.
So I remember it could be looked at the footage.
I was holding the camera and he was like, brother, you can get paid from this.
It's like, Bro, this is worth $100,000. He looked at his manager, Ali, uh,
shout out to ivy and he was like, get this, get him, give him some money.
He deserves this. And then I gave it to the UFC to use for embedded and um,
I thought it was that was just sit and they promoted the fight with it and I was
like, damn,
I should've just leaned my head to the right and got hit by the Dolly so I not
have to be doing it a, you know, a go fund me's and Shit.
This is the thing that drives me crazy. Saved you believe something, right.
And then if you go online and you read something else and that something else is
contrary to what you believe and you start believing in that something else
somehow or another, that's bad.
This is one of the great arguments against censorship is like you have to figure
out what the fuck makes sense.
The only way to figure out what makes sense is to read all kinds of things,
to engage with all kinds of content.
The idea that we're supposed to protect people because we know what's right.
We know what's correct. Well, who are you? Let me, let me talk to you.
Have you think you know what's correct?
You're the arbiter of free speech or the arbitrage of, of,
of logical discourse and and common sense in this world.
Let me ask you things. Let me talk to you.
Let me get to the heart of how you feel.
How do you feel about trans kids transitioning when they're six?
How do you feel about all sorts of crazy weird things that have just been
propped up as logical and makes sense? How do you, how do you feel about war?
How do you feel about abortion? How do you feel about ghosts? How, who are you?
Who are you and you just,
you just get to choose whether or not someone lean or information that comes to
them leans left or right. I think it's preposterous.
I just think it's incredibly dangerous because you have to have an unbelievably
complex and nuanced perspective in order to be able to dictate what makes or
does not make sense. And you,
you have to have a lot of information at your disposal. You have to have a lot.
If you're talking about something like Venezuela,
let's look at that for example,
look at what you know and then look what you see in what you would call
progressive, left wing media.
That to your knowledge is incorrect and is basically propaganda points that's
being redistributed in this way that is palatable.
Now imagine if the people decide that you Abby Martin or somehow or another part
of some right wing conspiracy now and they,
they're going to sensor your voice and Sensor Europe because it doesn't fit in
to this narrative that there,
but because you need so much information to be able to really understand what's
happening in this one part of south South America. That word, right. Exactly.
It's so complex.
Well, they treat us like children. Um,
and they think that we're not smart enough to actually discern what is, um,
information that we need. And I mean, I want the Russian perspective.
I want the Venice right in perspective.
I want the Chinese perspective because I feel like we're smart enough to really
determine our own reality based on all the available information.
Well, this is where we're fucked,
is that we don't have a reliable independent source that's not filled with
hyperbole and emotion and, and,
and dunking on people and screaming and insulting.
And I want someone who can break things down logically and clearly with no
ideological bend. They, you're not leaning left, you're not leaning right. What,
where is that and why? Why doesn't that exist?
Because it's not necessarily human. And, and you know,
people have opinions and they have biases and either they couch those biases in
like these think tanks and pretend like they're these unbiased journalists.
Or are they just kind of wear it on their sleeve? Like I do, um,
with empire files and media roots, which is my, you know,
my news organization that I do with my brother Robbie, but I mean,
we tried to lay it out, but we also don't hide where we're coming from.
I almost appreciate that more than, than a lot of these journalists,
so-called journalists who are really kind of stenographers who pretend like they
are unbiased and they're like, I'm just giving it to you straight.
And at the end of the day, they're, they're really not,
they're trying to toe a line and they're trying to push a certain perspective,
but it's just not obvious. Yeah.
That guy a in San Diego,
I was telling you about the a a man threw sandals at me this weekend at my show.
Yeah. What happened is we called them sandals Steve. So, uh, this is the most,
there's two embarrassing parts of, of this story for this man. The show,
the Sunday show was fucking phenomenal in San Diego. It was so fucking dope.
We sold out the weekend and then Sunday show was incredible.
Everyone's having a good time. I'm joking around at the end of my show,
very end about people in San Diego think wearing sandals with jeans as
appropriate. And I was like, that's just that San Diego.
It's like buttoned down, but I have sandals on.
It's like douchebags fucking have their toes out but wear like pants and some
guys are gay. I'm like, let me guess you're wearing jeans with sandals.
And he put, brings up a sandal. And I'm like, Myra Sandals, Steve Sound Caesar.
But, and he goes, my name is Steve. And I was like,
this fucking guy is fucking guys you this set. No.
And I fucking wish I was the only one. I didn't fucking record course.
That's the universe coursing. So, so, so, so I turned to the,
I turned to the left and this dude throws a fucking,
I see it on the corner of my eye. Oh my God.
But when the Sandal hit the curtain, uh, actually, and the lawyer,
they have the old comedy store sign. Do you know that they bought,
they brought that down. The old neon had the old neon. Now it hit the neon.
And I was like, dude, what the fuck was that shit? And it kind of, you know,
when something doesn't register, cause I was like,
no way that if you broke the neo dude, bro murder.
So I turn and then as I'm turning another sandal gets tossed on stage,
not throwing, but like tossed. And I immediately, I was like, wait,
what the fuck? And he's going like this bro.
And that fuck staff is coming up and grabbing this fucking moron.
And two dudes are standing up in the audience, you're ready to like swing.
Like people were like, it was a commotion. And I was like, what the fuck?
And he goes, I'm just shooting around. We couldn't run. And they were like,
get the fuck out dude. And he goes, come on man, I'm a big fan. I go, dude,
get the fuck out. You can't throw shit at me. Get the fuck out of here.
So they removed the dude.
But the best part or the most unfortunate part is it's his daughter's 21st
birthday and she's a big Fan, right?
Your shithead dad threw sandals at your fucking so of course if she's listening,
I love you. Thanks for being a fan.
Sorry your dad is a fucking moron and threw his sandals at us cause that's how
you get kicked out dude. He threw them at my fucking head.
[inaudible] missed my head by like a foot and he thinks I'm just kidding around
like no dude, it is not funny. You don't throw sand,
you can't throw sandals that Pete, you can can't throw shit at people.
You can't throw shit and the poor girl man,
I've never seen someone so embarrassed she was getting her purse and shit and
she's like,
you're like wavering through the crowd and the sun is like can I get back as
sandals? And I was like get the fuck out. It doesn't usually happen.
Someones rare, rare. You've got to, you've got to do some dumb shit.
It does happen.
No Dog Yoga community has went from, hey,
check out my Bakasana to check out my backside in. These are the pants,
right? A lot of yoga pants, pics, boody foodie booty.
Just booty alone is an industry. It is a giant industry. It's the grant. Yeah.
So what happens is you, you wake up in the morning,
you check your notifications, then your homie tags you. Oh, look at this chick,
the poem right now you have an erection. What's the first thing you do?
You like, ah, let me go to my browser, open incognito browser and hit pornhub.
Boom. Now you outta here. Right now your day's done.
You just depleted area energy. Right?
And this coming out of my book where I talk about, you know,
why you sent her golf and all that stuff, but you right,
that you shouldn't jerk off. Yeah. Never a well, there's a calculation.
You have a jerk-off algorithm yet as a jerk off algorithm. Uh,
it's created by the tower, the tower, Sta sexology.
And I think it's your age times two.
Know your age divided by times 100. I forget what it is. It's in my book.
I can't remember it. Uh, but I got it from the Tao. Right.
Which is why I don't have it memorized. Time Point eight times, 0.2 things.
H Times 0.2. Um, and then it tells you how many days. Right?
So at my age, I'm 38 now my age,
it's about seven and a half days between ejaculation to mean to maintain who I
am. Really? Yeah. And Am yes.
So a man strength is his balls. Right? Right.
So every time you deplete yourself, you're not the same man anymore.
You lose your superpowers. Now,
when you lose your superpowers to some, you know, ige model,
it's not even worthy.
Your orgasm doesn't feel the same as a natural interaction with a woman.
Right. You know what I mean? True. So you're, you're wasting your superpower on,
on, on like a fictional fantasy.
So you're wasting a percentage of your vital energy.
You're your vital energy as well as the proteins and minerals and zinc and
magnesium and all that stuff that you know is lost. Yeah.
I think it's equivalent to like two New York strip steaks, eggs,
oranges and apples or something like that. Really? Oh yes. A lot of vitamins.
That's why I have a one on the size of the loads you shoot though. No. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. That's why ladies should swallow. Whoa.
Jesus ladies. I'm sorry.
That's why you should ingest it.
If the man is healthy because it's a, it's a full meal. It's a full meal.
It's a full meal of nutrients that a man loses a bioavailable that way.
I wonder if anyone has done studies. I'm sure they have.
I bet people who've done like nutrition slash load studies,
probably a startup out there like trying to do this right now,
like calculate it into an app.
[inaudible].